first mascot can be found in your own
desk drawer that's right it's the
knotted ball of obsolete iPhone earbuds
let's get it because you don't know what
they're doing them go boo it's bad
enough to be obsolete
- here putz but to be booed after you
fail that's Louis rough crowd Liz Lemon
the election was four months ago but our
next mascot still has not recovered
it's the Hillary supporter who still
hasn't stopped crying let's get her out
here
[Applause]
she's upset but this is your time to
redeem yourself here you go Hillary
supporter who can't stop crying lip whoa
yeah incredible left all right here we
go
Liz Dunham in people are always happy
when they run into our next mascot it's
the free sample lady at Costco looks
like looks like we got some Kirkland
meatballs they're ready to go all right
are you all ready free sample lady from
Costco you set to go you think you knew
it let's go
those are suspiciously like ping pong
balls all right our next mascot this is
the saddest part is when they sweep up
the fake meatballs all right our next
mascot is an internet sensation it's the
crying Michael Jordan meme
everyone loves the crying Michael Jordan
mean if anyone can do this hits the
crying Michael Jordan meme go Michael
Jordan you okay Michael Jordan me
[Applause]
nicely done that I think we have to see
that again that was pretty exciting
let's take a look at that in slow motion
please and then no lift at all
there's a real sad corner over there
our next mascot is a team and they'd be
nothing without each other
it's dominatrix and [ __ ] dominatrix get
all right I hate to know what's gonna
happen to him if this doesn't work out
go for it go
[Applause]
no one has yet succeeded no one has
succeeded but if anyone can I think it's
this last last one our final mascot is a
perennial favorite he's back for his
second attempt dunk ladies and gentlemen
please welcome one of our all-time
favorites shrunken head Shaq can you do
it truck ahead Shaq
[Applause]
go do you want to try it one more time
let's go follow me oh he can't sing did
dad get his head so shrunken here's your
head alright alright now turn around
from a head check please you've got to
do this please you got to do this
tomorrow money riding on this drunken
hitch tag all right
[Applause]
[Music]
you